i mean think about it we we just uh
celebrated
uh martin luther king's birthday a man
who
who is associated with color blindness
um judge me by the content of my
character not
the color of my skin that is what the
civil rights movement used to be about
today the civil rights movement is about
black
lives matter not all lives
black lives say it or i'm coming after
you
we've turned the king sensibility
on its head i mean that's where we are
as a country and that's what the left is
as a country and i don't think that joe
biden feels he can
he can oppose that and succeed
politically
in the democratic party so i think he's
doing
what he feels he needs to do he needed a
he needed a black woman
as a running mate so he found a black
woman to run
um and i think he's checking off the
boxes
in terms of race and gender and sexual
orientation
right down the list because that is what
today's left demands
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
senior fellow at the manhattan institute
a wall street journal columnist and
author of the upcoming book
maverick a biography of thomas soule
jason reilly welcome to the reuben
report
thanks for having me i am glad to have
you here i thought this would be
the right week to have you on uh not
only because the doc is coming out
uh but obviously monday was mlk day
there's a lot going on in the world
and i've been following what you do and
what the manhattan institute does
for quite some time so i'm looking
forward to the chat for the people that
don't have any idea who we are who who
is jason reilly and why
is he on the reuben report
well uh i'm a journalist uh i've been uh
affiliated with the wall street journal
for about a quarter century now
and um i write a political column for
them a weekly column mostly about uh
urban
issues uh crime uh immigration race uh
economics and so forth and
um uh and i'm also like you a big fan
of thomas soule uh and i've written a
few books over the years and my most
recent one
is a biography of of thomas sol which is
being published right around the same
time
that uh a documentary film on his life
that i narrate
is also being uh being released yeah so
the book is coming out actually on may
25th and we'll put the pre-order link
below the doc
is actually coming out this weekend on
some uh
public tv stations and then and then
streaming services and all that good
stuff
and obviously uh you know i know that
you know how much thomas soul
uh has affected me and i'm actually i'm
honored to be to be in the dock and you
use some of the footage from our
from our interview uh that we did up at
stanford
um but you know you just hit on a bunch
of the hot topic stuff of the day and
and as we're taping this today it is
uh joe biden's inauguration but you
mentioned you talk about crime
immigration urban issues things like
that now as a wall street journal guy
my audience can probably put together
that you you lean somewhat right
are you hopeful are you worried
what do you feel about the incoming
administration right now
on the issues that you care about well
um i i care about uh how divided we are
as a country
right now and i'm hoping that um
joe biden can lower lower the volume a
little bit
um i think that's gotten gotten way out
of hand as we saw is what happened at
the at the capitol earlier
earlier this month uh so i'm hoping
that um that that's a priority of his
um and and and and maybe maybe he'll be
able to do that he's
uh i'm encouraged uh by by by some of
the things he's done so far um
some of his cabinet pics um i think have
been uh
uh quite moderate in comparison to what
we could have had we don't have a
uh you know uh secretary warren at
treasury or
uh secretary uh bernie sanders running
the labor department
um so so i uh i am hopeful there with
some of his uh choices that he's made on
the other hand um
you know i'm quite disturbed at the
direction of the democratic party
in in recent years with the rise of the
progressives
um the uh uh you know this sort of woke
left disturbs me the black lives matter
movement types disturb me and um
the fact of the matter is that joe biden
um is the head of a party that's moved
quite a bit to the left since the last
time he was in the white house
and while he's a guy who i think has
spent a career trying to find the center
of the democratic party and
and stay right there the fact is the
party itself has moved left and so i
think we're
i fear we're going to get a lot more of
the identity politics
that we had under under president obama
and and that worries me because he left
office
with race relations in pretty pretty bad
shape i i think they continue to sour
under
under president trump but but they were
already pretty bad
when trump got into office as a result
of what happened under obama
and i'm i'm fearful that um that that
biden and his
adherence to identity politics and so
forth will um
will keep us going in that direction
unfortunately yeah are you
kind of surprised how much biden has
embraced identity politics because as
you're pointing out he's not
actually we think or at least his
history is not one of the
sort of really far left you know the
bernie elizabeth lawrence
it is more of a centrist but it's pretty
clear
that you know he's saying okay well we
got pete budaj so we have a gay
transportation
secretary and we got a trans i think
assistant
health secretary or deputy health
secretary nobody
cares if you have gay people or trans
people and black people and all of these
things that's wonderful but
of course you want qualification are you
surprised he's doing or do you think do
you think he's just doing a certain
amount of placating them
to to then get back to the center that
would be music to my ears but but i fear
that energy that you're talking about
yeah i think he feels he has to do it
that this is where
where the party is um and and
and if anything uh it's gotten worse
in recent years uh with i mean
think about it we we just uh celebrated
martin luther king's birthday a man who
who is associated with color blindness
judge me by the content of my character
not the color of my skin that is what
the civil rights movement used to be
about
today the civil rights movement is about
black
lives matter not all lives
black lives say it or i'm coming after
you
we've turned the king sensibility on its
head
i mean that's where we are as a country
and that's what the left is
as a country and i don't think that joe
biden feels he can
he can oppose that and succeed
politically
in the democratic party so i think he's
doing
what he feels he needs to do he needed a
he needed a black woman as a running
mate uh so he found
a black woman to run um and i think he's
checking off the boxes
in terms of race and gender and sexual
orientation
right down the list because that is what
today's left demands
that's it's it's very bizarre i've asked
this of a few other people that i've had
on the show but are you
shocked at the way these these seemingly
bad ideas have taken a hold of so many
of our institutions and our political
elite and our
our media institutions and everything
else
i i am i'm i'm quite concerned um and
there's so little
so little pushback um uh there's there's
even even on the left they're canceling
each other
uh if if if if you don't toe the line
on on certain issues uh everyone from uh
from a stephen pinker to an andrew
sullivan to
you you you're not allowed to step out
of line over there or the mob
will come after you and i find it i find
it extremely
uh disturbing um i i i don't think
that uh it's helpful in terms of
addressing real issues in society it
keeps us
at each other's throat but um this is
how
uh the democratic party wins votes this
is how they gen up
their base and and and and these that
what we're going
through right now with the critical race
theory i mean i'm old enough to remember
uh when this when this stuff started uh
back in the 70s and 80s in particular
but it was sort of limited to academia
and now it's spilled over into the
mainstream and we're talking about
uh you know unconscious bias and
and these ridiculous diversity training
programs and
and and demanding the self-abasement of
whites and
and to acknowledge their privilege and
all the rest this is i think this is
horrible for the country just absolutely
horrible and
and i think all of it will be ascendant
in a joe biden presidency unfortunately
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell